exactly yeah and it could just be done
yeah it's also super insecure yeah I
also think like I'm insecure me too
[Music]
all right we got another thing from uh
North Texas this time oh cool is it for
Nick only he will like it you will not
like it oh why I'm sorry
so I we have a married couple driving a
minivan the guys I hate it already the
guy's name is Zayn the girl is Paola
yeah they're driving in a minivan and
they're being tail guided tail Guided
tailgated by another car it's getting
pretty close to them so they decide to
merge to the right to let this dude pass
because she's being a dick right so as
he passes Zayn flips him off oh no idiot
why just let them pass yeah dude he
flips him off which he also mentions
that his wife Paola hates it when he
does this then don't do it Go in zany
again
do it some people he does it all the
time we'll shoot you just for that yeah
because they're crazy nah that doesn't
happen oh no so what happens is the car
pulls up next to them and fires several
why are you laughing Nick why would you
say I would like this what I didn't even
get a punchline yet you're really
laughing yeah why are you laughing you
guys were all laughing when he said that
I wasn't I definitely wasn't laughing
ooh got you there what's the funny stop
being mean to him roll the tape back
what's the funny part he [__] around
it irony it's not the contrast of saying
no they don't get shot they got shot
immediately after so yeah they end up
both getting shot did they die but his
wife dies oh but he lived to tell the
story but he lives and he [__]
but isn't that crazy how [__] happens
like that I didn't make that up that's
really what he said did he actually not
lie and say yeah I flipped them off and
then he shot me that's what he said not
to victim blame but he asked for it
kinda not at all dudes most realities
are just so [__] skewed you just
can't test people's realities are so
skewed like you cannot no you should be
able to [__] flip people off it's
called freedom of speech bar yeah and
you shouldn't be assaulted for it that
guy was provoking we live can you flip
off a gorilla yeah they don't throw [__]
at you no no [__] pull your head off
your head or your body yeah because
that's what gorillas hate they hate
getting flipped you could flip off a
gorilla and he'll probably like think he
did Magic I was with you for a second
then you pulled out the gorilla thing
now I'm kind of like damn it I can't
support it that guy was like yeah you
should be able to stare a Rottweiler in
his eyes but guess what he's gonna bite
you in the face maybe if he has anger
issues but yeah you should be able to
[__] stare in his house then flip off
the people you know that dog if you're
in California you could probably flip
off a good amount of people depending on
what city you're in if you're in La West
LA you could flip off a lot of people I
mean that didn't happen why because
you're not afraid of the gays well I
just think I'm lost I think in the
culture of driving out there everyone's
flipping everybody off I think there's a
difference between life not their work
California why you say out there like
you're not in California West L.A dude
there's a there's a there's a clear
difference between like like yeah it
should be illegal but there's also
common sense right so like you don't
want to provoke anything even if it's
legal to talk [__] yeah it's legal to
talk [__] right but if I [__] you
don't know if you're driving next to a
guy that just got out of jail and he's
[__] nuts yeah but and it's illegal
for him to shoot you right and he should
go to jail for it sure but at the same
time should you poke the bear yeah
especially when you know someone's
tailgating you and like they're acting
or like erratic on the road you don't
want to make that even worse by flipping
them off you just yeah like what's your
mission is your mission tonight to spend
time with your lady and have a good time
and get some pizza and watch a movie
then does this ad take you away from the
mission
do you guys do this or do you guys do
this I've never flipped anyone off of my
life that's not a problem that's true
I've never I've never done that I don't
flip anything because I'm not asking for
it I get a little bit of knuckle out a
little bit I only do this to my friends
yeah I only flip out friends it's like
it's like shocking like straight yeah
this feels like so forced
to like hold every finger because if I'm
gonna go like this to a stranger I might
as well drive into his car yeah you
might as well punch him I might as well
just go like this in yeah I've never
flipped anyone off yeah there's no point
I got like arthritis when I flip people
off but there are people out there that
believe like you should be able to be as
offensive as possible and nothing
happens to you and I'm all like I agree
I mean you can and it's illegal if
someone acts out violently and then they
should go to jail because they were they
you know because they lost it that's
still illegal but you did provoke them
and then that's the karma you [__]
around and you found out I think it's a
50 I agree dude I don't think they
should but you also asked for it some
people might be cool with it they might
just be like well [__] that guy like why
would you want to jeopardize
your whole family because you're upset I
just can't believe in the interview this
guy was like she hates when I do that
yeah yeah I think you probably felt he
probably I couldn't see how it happened
yeah I could see like him like yeah and
then the police like so what happened
so when I do that I could see all this
happened that was actually really good I
felt kind of sad she told me so read
that sentence
he wrote she was an innocent victim she
was a passenger in the car when I
flipped off the driver who put us in
danger she always hated past tense
because you [__] killed your wife you
dumb [__] and I did it anyway yeah
you're an idiot dude that's the guilt
that's the that's like I put us in the
situation because I was I was trying to
[__] around and find out um I'm glad he
recognized it though yeah
it's like a weird thing no don't put
faces to it because then it's too real
is that a stock photo a real photo
marriage license today they got married
they just got married they were going on
their phone their honeymoon yeah she
looks like a sweet lady too she looks
like well she doesn't like when he flips
them off so you know she has a lot of
sense yeah she was keeping him in line I
do feel bad for certain people though
that their world so like they've been
lucky enough to where they grew up in a
world where that's not even a
possibility where someone will blast
your ass for me it's common sense right
especially in La every summer road rage
happens there's a lot of people that
will just blast you because you cut them
off or whatever and so like if you grew
up in a world where that's not even an
option and then as like things just get
as far as like you're yelling at each
other in a car they're so ignorant to
how the world really can be did they
have I'm sorry maybe wasn't paying
attention did he have a gun too no so it
was just the other guy who was shooting
back and then he got shot as well but
his wife was the one who died yeah they
both got shot no he just blasted into
the car wouldn't you especially like I
don't know in like the state of Texas
just assume though that like you know
there's already rule very true oh it was
in Texas people just have guns on them
more likely you know I was for sure not
paying attention I don't I don't assume
text yeah I don't assume Texas because
that's not Texas Behavior that's more
California Behavior to flip people off
no no to just like randomly blast in
Texas it's like I am proud of the Second
Amendment I know it's a uh a privilege
and a right so everyone let's uphold
like like like let's not like let's say
if the teacher brings in this really
cool soda fountain all the kids are all
right be cool kid then we'll do a
homework or else we're gonna lose the
privilege that's Texas California it's
it's already illegal so [__] it
[__] you know what I mean yeah
because they don't it's like they
already go we have something really
special let's protect it it seems like
in a place where you can grow up with uh
guns being around that you would have a
better practice to impulse control yeah
because it's not I don't know I just
felt that it was safer there than here
like the small towns that they have
there we have small towns too but
there's still a lot of crime yeah this
[__] does happen in in Cali like more
for sure obviously well I mean there's
always going to be like an anomaly or
like a you know a bad egg right so I
guess it's just the [__] lesson of
just not provoking anybody because
unless you're also ready to engage I
think we have to touch upon what Joe was
saying like it's nice to be able to have
your LV bag sitting on the passenger
seat and then no one should be breaking
my car windows when I go inside to a
store right but then I grew up that
that's a reality if someone sees
something valuable yeah so even for me
like if I have a regular [__]
JanSport backpack if I'm gonna go
somewhere I put it behind the car seat
right like I'm not I don't even believe
anything that looks sure like anything
of value it's just you have to
understand what the reality is it's
crazy that some people do not understand
that yeah I used to be pissed about that
too but then I realized it's because
they didn't grow up like me right so
yeah like what's second nature to you
is just something that isn't even an
option for them well also people got to
learn the hard way you know what I mean
it's like you don't learn about your bag
being stolen until it gets stolen so
same thing like you don't think that
somebody's gonna shoot you even if you
flip somebody off maybe they're gonna do
something back but not you might not
think they're gonna shoot you it's just
that happened to be the hard lesson that
day there was this girl that uh like um
at my old Studio she left her purse on
the passenger seat of her car when she
like ran in and so somebody smashed her
window I had it all on on video someone
smashed the window took her back out mad
easy she was pissed about it and I was
telling her like why did you leave it on
the thing and she was like I'm just mad
because my gun was in my bag oh my gosh
that's even worse yeah it's even worse I
know and she's mad at him and I'm like
you can't I'm like did you are you from
out of state she said I grew up in
Burbank
wouldn't Burbank kind of [__] know
it's crazy but that's also that yeah
that's not how you treat weapons too
yeah if you have a weapon on you just
the other day I was pumping gas and then
um these Japanese tourists they rented
some motorcycles and then this lady
after she figured out how to pump gas
she was going into the store and her
wallet keys everything was just left on
her motorcycle seat thank God her other
friend was there and then she was just
like you can't do that in America and I
was listening to their conversation she
goes you can't just leave this is out in
the open like what are you doing yeah
Japan is really safe but it's like that
in Japan like you could literally just
leave your [__] wallet and your
things in your bag and then just go to
the store [__] pee come back whatever
right like it's yeah yeah so so I was
like that's [__] crazy but I think
it's like that like it's not a second
nature when you grow up so peaceful like
no yeah if you think like you know argue
with someone is the is the craziest
thing that can happen they don't think
like someone will murder you then you
know then you're then you're more
confident about arguing you know that's
crazy when I was in Shanghai I
accidentally like an idiot left my
Nintendo switch in the basket of the
mobike you know the little bike you can
rent and just ride around oh yeah I left
it in the basket when I checked the bike
back into the stall I came back four
hours later it was still sitting in
there wow
I like that too yeah where like people
leave the clothes you might even way
more yeah there's Bentley like on the
Bentley car and they'll go like to the
gym
[__] is Haram baby you can't steal stuff
another lesson this was designed for
friends
honestly I think that's right like if
you're gonna flick someone off you
better be planning to either get shot or
shoot them I do think the biggest theme
though is just knowing what your mission
is if your goal is to have a good time
don't do anything that leads away from
it yeah if you're having a good time
yeah pulling over was great that guy was
tailgating could have endangered you let
him go and then if your mission is to
have a go on a date then keep going on a
date yeah and if an altercation can be
over in a second why make it longer or
more confident like if if your goal is
to have a good time yeah let's have a
good time at the supermarket with your
family some guy like like shoulder bumps
you or whatever
like that's [__] literally going away
from what your mission was that day
exactly yeah and it could just be done
yeah it's also super insecure yeah I
also think like I'm insecure me too most
people don't deal like running a
conflict every day right or like if you
do you're you're dealing with normal
people so like you're you're just it's
more okay I guess for them to just like
get into a quick little argument and
then they move on with their day
but then I think you should avoid
conflict at all costs even if you look
like a [__] yeah because you just never
know when you're running into someone
that will murder you yeah the stakes are
too high plus if this guy's been doing
that and she hates it every time he does
it then he's kind of been racking up
that department so he yeah so you're
saying he deserved it no but I think he
I think he deserved to lose his wife I
don't think he deserved it but I think
he asked for it but I don't think he
deserves I think he I don't think anyone
deserves getting killed for flipping
someone off but no his probabilities got
higher right right right because one day
you're gonna run into the nut and
they're gonna kill you You're Gonna Roll
the Snake Eyes eventually yeah most
people you can flip them off and then
maybe the further still goes be like
let's fight like that guy that's like
pounding on your [__] window
to the Bruno Mars song and then just
touch me
[Music]
thank you